hello we are delighted you joined us for
today's live webinar a keynote
presentation where innovation and
regulation meet I am Christina mihalik
of levers and I'll be moderating the
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by labyrinth relieving
scientific social networking website in
provider a virtual events in use
webinars to learn more visit lapras com
let's get started you can post questions
to the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so as we type them in the Q&A box which
will open we click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problem seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report the problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the screen this is an educational
webinar that's offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
ever please click on the c/e button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of the web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit it is now my
pleasure to introduce today's speaker
Laura tune PhD personalized medicine
staff at the Food and Drug
Administration Center for Devices and
Radiological health dr. into PhD is a
member of the personalized medicine
staff at the Food and Drug
Administration in the Center for Devices
and Radiological health prior to joining
the FDA she was director of policy for
the ovarian cancer National Alliance
where she ever saw congressional and
regulatory policy including issues
pertaining to use in regulation of
genetic technologies prior to that she
was
American Society of Human Genetics
genetics and public policy fellow from
2012-2013 and worked in the house of
representatives on issues related to
genetic testing and genetic
non-discrimination dr. to holds a PhD in
biochemistry cellular and molecular
biology from the johns hopkins
university school of medicine once again
it is my pleasure to introduce dr.
chance dr. fuse the floor is yours
wonderful thank you Christina and good
morning to all of you it's my pleasure
to talk to you for the next 45 minutes
or so and then answer questions about
some of our recent work regarding the
regulation of next-generation sequencing
test as I mentioned what I'd be happy to
take questions at the end and please ask
them as you come up with them so first
I'd like to take a step back and frame
where a lot of this work that we've been
doing over the last couple of years of
come from so as I'm sure many of you are
familiar with the precision medicine
initiative was announced a couple years
ago with the goal of enabling a new era
and medicine through research technology
and policies and empower patients
researchers and providers so what is the
FDA's role here so we work it is our
mission to both promote protect the
public health by regulating the safety
and effectiveness of genetic tests in
this case so under the precision
medicine initiative we have sought to
develop an approach suit it's the unique
nature of current ngf tests and have
been working to adapt our regulatory
policies regarding these tests so that
we meet our twin goals of promoting
innovation in this space but also
providing patients with safe and
effective tests and I'll talk quite a
bit more about that Peter
so so there are several things that need
to happen for precision medicine could
be successful so of course patients need
safe and accurate tests that reliably
identify their variation and make sure
that that is clinically meaningful for
them we need learning healthcare systems
and enable researchers and clinicians to
learn from all of this information that
we're generating about genetic variation
and disease and help that use that to
inform patient experience we need to
develop targeted therapies that are more
efficacious and have less ability rear
side effects for patients based on their
you know specific genetic alterations
and of course we will need to update
research and regulatory policies to make
sure that we're really capitalizing upon
all of these all this new research and
development of new tree shirts new
treatments while doing our job to
protect efficient so FDA's role in the
PMI as I hinted earlier is really to
implement new regulatory policies that
promote research and accelerate the
translation of precision medicine
technologies and the treatments that
benefit patients and so the next this
sort of outlines that what I'm going to
talk to you about today first we need to
develop and implement standards that
assure the analytical test that the
analytical of quality of test is met so
that is do they measure what they say
that they're going to measure in an
accurate way we also support the use of
publicly accessible genetic databases
for evidence of clinical relevance
addition of experience so are we are we
crowdsourcing data generation about what
an individual genetic variant might need
for a patient and then finally we are
developing open source tools that help
test developers meet standards so this
is a platform that we've put together
called precision FDA without pocket
bit more about at the end of our talk
today so as I mentioned it sort of
outlines what I'm going to talk to you
about today so first I'm going to
discuss a to dress guidances the first
which address is how we have been
thinking about developing analytical
standards to make sure that test
developers can ensure that analytical
validity of their tests seconds I'll
talk about a second draft guidance which
discusses how test developers can
leverage publicly accessible databases
to support the clinical relevance of
their tests and in third I'll talk about
precision FDA which is our platform for
bioinformatics okay and so just to give
you a little background on FDA as I'm
not sure how many folks on are familiar
with what we do here and how we actually
evaluate test so you can think about the
need for a new paradigm for
next-generation sequencing test because
it's so different than all of the
different diagnostic should have come
before it so conventional Diagnostics
you know single gene assays for example
have a low or medium resolution they
usually detect a couple of different
analytes maybe maybe all of the
different variants within a teen or
maybe even just a handful of areas of a
gene you know no to the positive and
cancer so gentle usually a test has a
single disease indications and evidence
used by a test developers to support of
that test and a premarket submission is
usually gathered by the sponsor self or
they may be able to leverage um
literature as well so next generation
sequencing based tests really blow that
whole paradigm open obviously if these
tests use high resolution technology
generating millions of pieces of
information about you know every every
very intimate
every day they're in a genome and you
might get information back about
thousands of individual variants that
you think we have the same test can be
used in many different diseases so we
break apart that one test one disease
paradigm and then obviously because
there's so much unknown about about the
individual genetic variants that we all
harbor it's necessary to use
crowd-sourced data to generate the
evidence necessary to support a
premarket submission for one of these or
it may be necessary to do so so when the
FDA reviews a test for prior to it being
marketed we generally look at a couple
different things so the first is
analytic validity and this is what our
first guidance focuses on a little
pocket awful lot about today so does the
test correctly detect the analytes that
it claims to how precise is that test
what are the limits of detection or
measurement if there are any you know if
the sample is very dilute can you not
get a good read on it for example the
second thing you look at is clinical
validity so does the test correctly
identify a disease or condition so you
might die for example with a blood
glucose test may analytics may be
analytically valid it might correctly
detect the level of glucose in your
blood and if you are looking at diabetes
that's clinically valid obviously
there's a lot of literature out there
that shows that those two things are
related if you're running a blood
glucose test I'm looking at whether or
not you might have cancer that's not
clinically valid so so clinical validity
is sort of the clinical relevance of
whether is a variant you're looking at
in this case where genetic variant where
analyte has any clinical relevance to
disease that you're claiming
we would also look at the clinical
sensitivity specificity of predictive
values and and by statue clinical
validity must be assessed and relies
upon valid scientific evidence which
we'll talk a little bit more about what
are what our definition about scientific
evidences oh finally we would also look
at the labeling around the test so not
only one of the test developer might say
or promote about the test but also are
the directions for you is clear is what
you say about the test truthful or not
misleading and of course all of this is
based on the intended use of the test so
so what you a test developer are
claiming the test is used for so first
we'll talk about our analytical
standards draft guidance which we
published in july of last year now it's
entitled the use of standards and FDA
regulatory oversight of NGS based tests
in vitro diagnostics or tests of used
for diagnosing germline diseases and
I'll give a quick overview of this
guidance and then talk about some of the
nitty-gritty of it and how we arrived at
where we did but I just want to say
briefly that we have for the past couple
of years been engaging with the
community to develop these guidance as
these hosted for workshops and had a
number of different webinars and white
papers and have solicited quite a bit of
public feedback about the guidances that
we put forward I'll mention that they're
in draft and so all of the
recommendations in them are just at
their draft they're not legally
enforceable and nothing that I'm going
to discuss here today is for
implementation there of course continue
to be interested in engaging on public
feedback regarding these guidance
documents and so you know as we move
forward with these projects look forward
to continuing to engage with you in the
community and around around this work so
in summary this dress guidance has a
very limited scope first it's applicable
only to germline whole exome sequencing
or targeted panels I will talk a little
bit more about the scope in a minute it
makes a series of technical
recommendations for how much generation
sequencing test developers can design
and then validate their test to
demonstrate that are analytically valid
it accommodates different test designs
components and indication so we hope
that it's very flexible approach and
lots of different test developers can
use it so it's not sort of a
one-size-fits-all paradigm and we hope
that this can form the basis of future
FDA recognized standards or special
controls and I'll talk quite a bit more
about that later but FDA typically will
regulate or it will recognize standards
and these are consensus documents that
are put out by the community around
things like analytical validity so we'll
talk a little bit more about the
implications that that has four test
developers and then finally the guidance
discusses a potential expedited path to
market for test fit community standards
so first the scope of this guidance
document it applies only to targeted or
whole exome sequencing NGS based tests
that are intended to aid to aid in the
diagnosis of individuals with a
suspected term line disease or other
conditions so it's a pretty limited
scope we wanted to we thought when when
applying this new paradigm about how we
would evaluate a test rather than
looking analyte by enolate looking at
the test that detects multiple enjoys as
a whole we really wanted to fight off an
arrow an arrow education at first is to
make sure that we were thinking about
the right things and what would propose
as feasible for community so when tech
developers
approach analytical validation of their
tests there are two general approaches
that they could take so the first on the
on the left hand side of this continuum
discusses performance standards and so
these are the use of predefined
acceptance criteria that a test won't
have to satisfied using this approach
FDA would provide tech developers with
specific targets that they would have
some meat but overall there'd be less
flexible so for example we would provide
specific benchmarks on accuracy and
precision metal developer would have to
meet with their tests on the other side
of the spectrum is a design concept
approach where this outlines of process
by which a test developers were design
develop and validate a test iteratively
and as consistently be able to generate
test that meets their user needs with
performance characteristics that allow
for clinical interpretation so for
example this would be and add validation
of a test if any criteria components are
changed and we in our workshops leading
up to the publication of these guidances
Jeff guidances asked for stakeholder
feedback on which of these approaches
folks would prefer and we actually heard
that overwhelmingly most people would
prefer sort of a blend of the two they
want some sort of specific performance
standards today so that a text would
need to meet and and this is coming from
test developers you know saying you know
any any tested offers and accuracy below
X fresh holds we know it's not a good
test and we really wouldn't want that
out of the market and then also folks
wanted a blend of some of those design
concepts they're so so not needy not
indicating not needing to meet specific
benchmarks for every single thing that
you're going
to measure but being able to validate
entire test and to end okay and so as I
mentioned earlier so jobs guidance
provides a series of technical
recommendations to describe the approach
to the test design is our goal furnace
to accommodate multiple different test
designs components and indications and
so on and we hope that this can form the
basis of special controls or FDA
recognized standards in the future so
right I'd like to talk a little bit
about the test design so at FDA we think
about or recommend that when accessible
for designing a test that they need to
think about a couple different things so
we'll need to think about sorcerer
intended use so wouldn't I actually plan
on this test being used for is it is it
a targeted targeted sequencing panel
just to look for genetic alterations and
kids with suspected entrance fee or
hearing loss for example or do you want
to look at the entire XO of children
with developmental delays and
interesting to find you want to think
about what your user needs are so so
what kind of specimen types are you
getting what kind of information do
parents or physicians went back that
kind of thing you also need to think
about what regions of the genome you're
able to interrogate and it was what a
coverage level for example if you know
that there are regions of the genome
with clinically relevant genes that
you'd like to sequence but you know that
they're tough to sequence so so what do
you do in that case you'll have to think
about that season to the performance of
your test and then you also need to
think about what components and methods
you have at your disposal to use in your
and so all of these components influence
your test designed and so when thinking
about validating a test using a design
standards approach or design concepts
Sanders approach you have to think about
the test design feeding into the test
performance so having encompass all of
that information and saying you need a
test that runs a tech specifications and
you know reports all information on
these variant regions at X coverage what
kind of test performance do you need and
so how do you design a test to make sure
that you get that performance you also
probably want to have some predefined
test run quality metrics so how do you
know if on a run level your chest filled
or not so you'll wanted to define those
you'll then use all this information
assemble a test and invalidate it to
make sure that it's meeting the criteria
that you set forward when you designed
your test in the first place and so this
is an iterative process and it might be
the kind of thing that a test developer
willing to set through a couple
different times as a you know develop
their test to make sure that they're
hitting all of the different all of the
different criteria that they would like
to and so the draft guidance discusses
in you know in some detail how to do
this process we also included some as
many folks up for some individual
performance characteristics so the other
side of the continuum so we identify
performance metrics and set minimally
accepted values that accessibility need
to meet for the test to be considered
analytically valid the guidance
specifies for overall metrics it should
always be assessed for set accuracy and
that could be by measuring the positive
predictive value negative predictive
values technical pretty good value
the precision so by looking at the
reproducibility and repeatability of
their essay you need to know the limit
of detection so below what coverage are
you not confident in the calls that
you're you're generating for example and
then we also look at the analytical
specificity so if you're going to
targeted panel and you know that there's
cross reactivity with pseudogenes of
some of the things that you're looking
for how are you dealing with with with
with a minimizing that issue we also
provide general recommendations for
studies to evaluate the performance so
we just find elements that should always
be included in validation experiments so
things that are important to FDA that
you should evaluate the performance and
to end of your test so if you change a
component you know you change a the
library prep or you change a piece of
your bio informatics pipeline that could
be considered a you know a major
component and you need to revalidate the
test intend we want to see validation
from represented relevation data from
representative areas of the genome so
are you able to sequence you know even
sequence regions are you able to
sequence more difficult for sequence
regions so for example areas with high
TV content for example are you able to
to find different variant types so snv's
small window structural variants copy
number variations for example are you
able to detect all of those if not thats
that's probably you know if your test
doesn't need to detect the large
structural variant that's fine you would
just need to say hey so if it does and
you want to you want to claim that
you're able to detect those large
structural variants for example you
would need to have that
patient data so that you could actually
do so and again obviously you want to
make sure that all of the areas that
you're able to sequence and you're
providing validation data for related on
to an indication that your your your
test is trying to meet we'd also want to
see a dimension that if there are
certain things that use your test cannot
reliably detect with accurate actors
with adequate accuracy precision that
you say so so you defined what
limitations your test might have and
then you'll want to provide validation
data for all of the different specimen
types that you intend to accept for your
test and conduct commun ability studies
if necessary finally also test
developers should determine the number
of specimens required to validate all of
these tests the guidance also provides
some other recommendations so
recommendations are all around when
Sanger confirmation by E necessary to
confirm of rare variant that you find
this is not something that we'd want to
see as part of the submission but
necessarily but you should define win
when how we need to be used and how that
might affect your validation studies we
also have some recommendations around
variant annotation and filtering how
information should best about test
performance should be presented on a
test report how result should be
communicated clearly and then finally
modifications so if you do change one of
those critical components of your test
on how you and then solid eight to show
that it's it's consistent with your test
performance before the pappadeaux my
vacation took place
so finally we believe that all of these
recommendations so before I talked about
before I talk about that let me let me
just talk about regulatory
considerations so next generation
sequencing test for the intended use
described here are currently class three
or high-risk tests just by regulatory by
legal default because FDA has not seen
one of these tests and classified it
before we believe that it would be cost
three or illegally it would have to be
classy however we believe this possible
to classify these types of class two or
moderate risk devices and the draft
Biden fully outlines what FDA believes
it needs to support this classification
so if we receive one of these tests
initially it would be defined as class
three just by you know um by the law we
would request then that the festival
apartment was called a de novo request
and we could then potentially down
classify the test two class two or
moderate risk and provide what are
called special controls along in the
future and new special controls might
make up some of the things that are
outlined in this guide it's a type of
analytical validation that we would want
to see for this test type and finally
the science energy it's a possibility in
the future we might be able to exempt
this whole test type from premarket
notification provided that all of these
tests are able to meet those special
controls outlined in the draft guidance
so the technical recommendations in the
draft guidance can serve as general
recommendations special controls and I
should just mention for those of you who
work in labs these are not for like
don't run level special
controls that you might include in annex
you know control as you might include an
experiment so the sort of a legal term
apart here at the FDA and these we just
mean specific criteria that your tests
would have to meet so like those
outlined in this draft guidance or they
could serve as standard so CDRH where I
work at the FDA has a robust standards
recognition program so far we've
recognized over a thousand different
standards that are used in the
analytical validation of devices and
diagnostic tests so standards are
developed by standard developing
organizations or SPOs these are
consensus bodies usually their domestic
or international and they include
experts and under relative banquet
experts from across across the area that
they're they're putting out a standard
on so examples of some standards might
be the performance characteristics of
attacks or testing testing methodologies
or how does how to meet QC requirements
for your laboratory in the molecular
diagnostic space some of the standards
organizations they are typically working
in this area are like to have a clinical
laboratory standards Institute feels I
for simple so if a if a standard
developing organization develops one of
these standards and we hope that some of
the information without one anesthetist
would would make up what that standard
would look like FDA could recognize it
and conformance with that standard could
support a reasonable assurance of safety
and effectiveness which is our standard
to to approve or
proved a device is of course would be
voluntary if a test developer says you
know that standard is great but I choose
to you know validate my test my own way
they could certainly do that and come in
however they would like to and then
again a declaration of Conformity would
be something that perhaps an independent
third party what effects to make sure
that successive elzar is meeting the
standard for their tests and and that
could be used in to demonstrate that
you've met the standard in different SS
and it was great ballad so um one thing
i want to say actually about standards
before i move forward is that the
actually so the real the real benefit to
using a standards-based approach is that
when we issue special controls around a
certain test type they're not easily
updated by the agency so we tend to have
a lot of policies and bureaucracy that
we have to move through but standards
developing organizations that could put
out offenders with the same information
they're often updated annually and FDA
can recognize each iteration of that
standard so the technology advances
there can be updated and FDA can
recognize it so standards move a little
bit more quickly than any FDA camp so
and another another thing that would be
advantageous is that when our
conventional approach any modifications
made to a test would require FDA review
of that package however standards could
or modifications could be one of the
components that included in the standard
which would make things quickly
a4tech developer so they predefined how
they're going to make modifications and
validate them then we wouldn't need to
see a resubmission of that issue of
course it takes it does take a while for
the community to develop standards and
leave those efforts are currently
underway so in the absence of standards
or the test developers interested in
using this approach before standard put
out you can use special controls in that
case too so next I like to take the next
few minutes to talk about our second
draft guidance the use of public human
genetic variance databases to support
clinical validity for a next generation
based test so to benefit to using
publicly available genetic databases are
obvious so the evidence house within
them can be generated by multiple
parties aggregated data can provide a
stronger evidence base so often what the
information is housed in these genetic
databases could reflect the current
state of scientific knowledge about a
particular variant and linked to a
disease or condition and as the clinical
evidence and proves all of this
information gets put into databases and
new interpretations about that data
could be supported so stated bases have
the potential to speed evidence
development for next generation based
tests since the evidence house in these
databases is generated by multiple
parties it's updated quickly and it's
really reflective of what's going on in
the community
so determine whether an NGS based test
has a reasonable assurance of safety and
effectiveness the agency relies upon the
review of valid scientific evidence that
would need to be built to support the
clinical performance while analytical
and clinical performance of this test so
this is the definition in fact that FDA
relies upon but some examples of what
constitutes all scientific evidence are
well controlled investigations well
documented case histories connected by
qualified experts reports of significant
human experience of the device and
peer-reviewed literature so notably this
is also the type of information it could
be held in a publicly accessible
database and so we believe that if
appropriate controls were in place
around the databases a certain quality
criteria were met that the data is
housed in publicly accessible databases
might need the definition about
scientific evidence and could be used to
support the clinical validity of the
test so in the past FDA has relied upon
it's been able to use genetic data bases
and the assertions that they make as
evidence of clinical validity for
improved and clear devices so in our
first example a couple years ago alumina
use a publicly accessible CSTR to
database as a source of evidence for
their FA diagnosing cystic fibrosis we
reviewed both the data within the
database and the interpretation process
of curators use and based on this
evaluation we thought that the data in
the database and the processes used to
generate it were sufficient to provide
assurance of the clinical validity of
the various reported by the test in a
second example myriad used its own
proprietary database as a source of
clinical validity for
acha analysis companion diagnostic tests
used in ovarian cancer treatment
selection so FDA review the interpretive
process that myriad used to classify
berries and again found the prophecies
that use were sufficient to provide
assurance of clinical validity and is
important to note here that because we
review the process by which the
interpretation occurs and found that
process to be sufficient Mary is allowed
to report to physicians
never-before-seen variants so newly
classified variants that they find so we
believe that these two different
decisions provide a model by which
genetic variant databases can be used to
support test quality so the draft
guidance we put out left last year
contains a number of different
recommendations for database
administrators to demonstrate that their
database can be considered a source of
scientific evidence the guidance also
outlines a voluntary database
recognition pathway so similar should
standards recognition pathway we just
returned discuss and then the guidance
describes how evidence and databases
could support the clinical validity of
NGS based test so you'll next discuss
the recommendations in greater detail
but broadly the rest upon a couple
different pillars so one transparency to
high-quality data validated processes
and formal procedures expertise of
expert interpretation and medical data
hygiene and all of these or things
through our experience with 50 or two
and hearing it we found to be important
to assess to making sure that the data
help within the database does need that
definition the solid scientific evidence
so the scope of this guidance document
it's only applicable to publicly
accessible databases of human genetic
variants so we're not going about
microbial genome identification we're
not talking about software that's
automated and you know automatically
classify their interpretation and
experience and when else are about the
primary databases either I think I think
we can skip this but the slides will be
available after the fact I know that in
the genetics communities are a lot of
different term of Arts around with
things like curation and interpretation
mean but here for the purposes of this
guidance interpretation means the
process by which data base personnel
evaluate the evidence regarding a link
between a variant and a disease or
condition and then how the link that
that did this personnel comes up with
that's the assertion that the database
done makes about a genotype-phenotype
correlation between particular variant
and disease or condition so we believe
that the evidence residing in many of
these variants genetic variant databases
could meet the definition of valid
scientific evidence and we then outline
a number of recommendations that if a
database administrator follows could
receive FDA recognition for their for
their database and we believe that then
those assertions could be in to support
the clinical validity of a test so as I
mentioned earlier the recommendations
really tender breasts in five different
buckets so transparency is key so we
would want to see transparency
information about your database
operations so our things adequately
documented you have versioning in place
you have sots for how you do things like
sure a date and pull it in from other
sources evaluate the quality of it how
you actually make assertions so so you
have a robust and validated process
underlying how you actually pull that
data together and then the insertion
about the link to a variance in the
disease we'd also want to see use of
standardized formats and disclosures
what formats are being used so so people
are using the database know what they're
looking at there are a number of
recommendations around data quality so
we'd like to see quite a bit information
about the data itself and its sources so
what kind of nomenclature you use we'd
like to see some metadata it's available
so the analytical performance of the
test you actually find the variance for
things like somatic variants we want to
see information about very little
frequency that kind of thing it's
important that you would have SOPs for
curation aggregation and interpretation
and the use of validated decision
matrices or protocols or scoring systems
they used to make those assertions we
also recommend the use of reliance upon
expert personnel so we want to know that
that's folks who are actually making
these decisions are adequately trained
they're experts in their field and we'd
also want to stan's permission around
disclosure of conflict of interest in
submissions finally we'd like to see
information about database hygiene so re
does a database follow all applicable
privacy security principles and so they
have a plan for digga preservation in
place in case the database runs out of
money or goes away or something like
that we would want to make sure this
knowledge in the loss the dress guidance
and outlines and FDA recognition tasks
briefly if a database is
being recognized it would submit a
voluntary request to the FDA for
recognition and I just want to emphasize
the process is voluntary we are not
requiring any databases to come and and
and it's really at the behest of the so
that the folks running the database what
I'm not they want to come in they would
then send us information about all of
the different call a needle is a
different recommendation so we just
outlined and the sign is also outlines
on processes for maintenance of that
recognition so a periodic review by FDA
of all your SOPs maybe spot-checking
assertions employed box we then believe
that if an FDA recognized data they make
some assertion is likely to constitute
valid scientific evidence and would
strongly support the clinical validity
of the genotype phenotype relationship
so if the test developer is interested
in bringing in a test for hearing
channel and we have said all of these
different assertions about the link
between these genetic variants and
hearing loss are valid scientific
evidence accessible the point to that
database and say this is what I'm using
and this is what I'm reporting out and
it's possible that we would say that
that is sufficient on its own and we
don't need to see any more clinical data
to support the clinical validity of that
test so in summary we believe that this
process provides a streamlined a pathway
for streamlined evidence generation it
takes advantage of the work already
being done in the genomics community and
we further believe that this approach
offers speed scalability and safety so
speed this approach from finalized could
provide test developers and efficient
path to market and connect patients with
the current state of scientific
knowledge about their variants
scalability test
a burst of large and small can benefit
because they all have access to the same
publicly available databases for
evidence generation and safety of this
approach would would encourage
innovation while still sharing patients
and healthcare providers that the test
that they use and rely on our safe and
effective and provide accurate and
meaningful results and with just a
couple minutes left because I want to
make sure to leave time for your
questions we're going to talk about
precision SBA Oh first let me put in a
plug for both of these guidance
documents they really are community
driven effort and so we do need help
with by the community we need folks to
help serve on standards developing
organizations bodies that are going to
look at developing new standards clearly
reference materials are kheili important
for animals validation of NGS taste test
data sharing so really building that
repository of information in these
publicly available databases of key to
creating sustainable and high-quality
databases and then obviously a lot of
those databases are built upon the backs
of volunteer so folks helping out with
curation and assertions are making
assertions is critical to to really
realize in this feature so the last
couple minutes I just want to put a plug
in for precision FDA which is our
community based platform for NGS i pay
evaluation and regulatory science
exploration I just want to be clear this
is a this is a regulatory science um a
platform right now it's not a regulatory
platforms but what it is is it's
actually just a sort of a sandbox where
folks who are doing next-generation
sequencing can upload their
bioinformatics pipelines upload
particular pieces are at
within those pipelines to in silico
mutagenesis to really challenge your
pipeline and it's a way for for the
whole community to sort of play together
it's a crowdsource cloud-based platform
it provides tools and open access
resources so there are if you were to
log in there are a number of different
apps and pipelines already available for
you to play around with in there and it
allows the whole community to test and
pilot and validate different approaches
so so far we've had over a thousand
different users create a councilman site
and these are folks from the entire sort
of genomics community so test developers
both large and small NIST the National
Institutes of Standards and Technology
FDA scientists scientists from NIH
standards bodies academic centers
industry and so on and so if you were
actually go to the website you would and
create an account you would see this
landing page so it gives you a taste of
what kinds of different things you can
do on the platform so you can upload a
file write a comparison watch a nap add
a nap or something like that and one
thing I did not mention here is our both
public and private spaces on the website
so if you you know have this new app
that you're going to try out and you
think it's really cool you can upload it
to the public space and have other
people play around with it if you really
just want to piss it a couple different
pipelines against each other using you
know files that you generated in your
own lab you could do that in your
private space and you don't have to
share that information with anyone and
just to be clear when I pay with anyone
I mean with anyone the FDA does not have
access to your private space so it
really is a sandbox floor for folks who
are interested and
this aspect of NGS to play around and we
have done a couple different challenges
through the through the site in the last
couple of months and I should just
mention that the site is about 14 months
old we launched in december of 2015 and
so it just has one year anniversary
that's so far we've run three challenges
a truth challenge a consistency
challenge and as well as a Pathan series
of challenges to try and get folks to to
you know add new add new components to
to to space we do plan on running
additional challenges in the future so
that you're not quite sure how this
might be useful for you maybe sign up
for an account and and get involved in
one of our future challenges so again we
really want to engage with the community
we think that this platform is a really
great way to do so if you have ideas for
types of challenges that you think would
fairly answer interesting scientific
questions or help move the ball forward
on how vital informatique pipelines work
get involved with us submit those
challenge ideas does we there are
discussion forums on precision SVA other
ways for you to get your feedback to us
we're really just interested in hearing
what your great ideas are since you're
the folks out in the field living and
breathing bioinformatics every day and
so with that I'd have to be happy to
open it up for questions but I just
wanted to note that there are a couple
of different email address is up here so
first is mine you can get in touch with
me with any questions you have the
second is the whole precision medicine
team here at FDA and then the third
word is if you have questions about that
platform precision FDA which I admitted
into justice to running shirt pretty
quickly feel free to contact the team
there too to get in wealth as well as
check out the website which might have
10 number your questions answered okay
the bad i'm happy to take any questions
okay um so one question that we often
get asked is who do these guidances
apply to so do they apply to labs it
only applies to conventional died thank
you doctor cares for your informative
presentation and sorry about that small
delay a quick reminder for our audience
on how to submit question simply Tyson
in the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window dr. KU's will
answer as many questions as time a
comment okay so without hesitation look
Japan the first question asked to do
these guidelines apply to collab
conventional IVD manufacturers etc um so
a variance of technical issue in line so
they apply to their voluntary guidance
guidelines and they apply to any party
that's interested in in using them so as
a IBD manufacturer think that this might
be a good approach for that for their
you know NGS based test that they're
bringing into the FDA for clearance or
approval then that is there certainly
free to use this path is a laboratory
that's developing an LD t that wants to
come and seek FDA approval or clearance
and their free Jesus as well it's not no
one is required to use this pathway just
want to be clear about that the hall
it's all voluntary um we just saw the
need for a different paradigm for how
agency could review these types of
and wanted to proactively provide one to
the community
thank you for your answer our next
question asks well all genetic test
developers including those that do not
use in gs based technologies be able to
use FB a recognized databases for their
submission thanks so in the in the draft
guidance we proposed that NGS based test
developers would be able to use these
genetic databases that get FDA right
that our FDA recognized however we see
receives a lot of public feedback from
the community saying that other types of
test developers such as you know genetic
technologies to rely on just sequencing
like Sanger sequencing or PPR would also
be appropriate candidates for this type
of for using these types of databases
and so as we move forward with
finalizing the guidance into something
we're considering and and I think really
moving towards any any sort of genetic
technology could benefit from this
pathway
thank you for your answer we are looks
like we're running a close one time so
when we have time for one last question
today and this question asks who do we
contact to open the channel to help well
luckily I've still got my slide up with
my email address so you can contact any
both myself and anybody else on the PMI
or precision FDA team depending on what
your where your interest lies we as I as
I hope emphasized we really do you think
about this whole this whole effort is
being community driven and so we're
really interested in getting community
feedback as well as engaging with y'all
about moving forward so so please feel
free to email me email the folks on our
team and and we look forward to working
with all of you
I would like to once again thank dr.
tunes for her presentation dr. kids do
you have any final comments you'd like
to leave us with today I think I just
encourage folks to check out precision
FDA online it's a really cool tool that
that I wish we'd have more time to talk
about but I think could be useful for
many many of your labs and I really want
to thank each and every one of you for
your time and attention today and please
do be in touch regarding getting
involved I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and thank lat roots
for today's educational webcast this
webcast can be viewed on the man's room
820 17 libraries polar you via email
when it is available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live Annette we look forward to
seeing here seeing you here next time an
elaborate goodbye